no
cuando la gente me pregunta mi opinión
sobre el futuro me pasa algo que me
imagino que pasará muchos de los que
estáis en esta sala y es que me miran
como si estuviera loco porque yo
realmente tengo opiniones muy optimistas
del futuro yo me imagino o sea yo confía
en nuestra especie creo que vamos a
superar los retos del cambio climático
por ejemplo a veces me huele un poco
loco me imagino convirtiéndonos en una
civilización tipo 2 construyendo una
espera de dyson alrededor del sol
y en días como el plan mis mejores días
de esto que te levantas y hace sol y te
sientes guapo digo igual hasta igual
está dejamos iniciarle piña la pizza
soñando a lo grande
pero es verdad que para alcanzar esa
especie prospera pacífica y respetuosa
con la cocina italiana va a ser
necesario cooperación
y la cooperación depende de la
diversidad cuando llego a diversidad
digo diversidad real no es solo la
diversidad de género o de raza que por
supuesto es imprescindible pero también
la diversidad de ideas incluso de ideas
políticas
y es que da igual que seamos de
izquierdas de derechas blancos
privilegiados o de una minoría estamos
todos muy sensibles con cualquier idea
un poquito diferente de la nuestra
parece que ya no es como que no estoy de
acuerdo es que no la aguanto no se
enfurecen
y es curioso porque tengo la sensación
de que con la polarización pasa lo que
pasa con el tráfico a todos nos molesta
pero nadie se siente responsable cuando
lo cierto es que nunca estás en un
atasco eres atasco
yo creo que esto pasa porque las redes
sociales han trasladado buen internet ha
trasladado algo tan humano como la
conversación y la convivencia a un
hábitat que no es el nuestro el de los
mamíferos o entornos virtuales
por eso digo que es tan necesario
recuperar el entorno físico las
comunidades físicas la historia es que
hace unos años dando clase quería hablar
con mis alumnos del impacto de internet
y de las redes sociales en la
polarización y en las relaciones
personales y les puse este ejemplo no sé
si conocéis la historia es la imagen de
un vídeo en el que una activista rusa
se graba
tirándole lejía y agua a la entrepierna
de hombres que están haciendo man spring
en el metro el spa está re de toda la
vida
y entonces les dije bueno esto es lo que
si esta chica y les plantea algo que os
plantea también a vosotros que os
forméis una opinión al respecto
inmediatamente a la izquierda de la
clase una chica se empezó a reír y dijo
pues mira me parece muy guay dice porque
el man es previamente muy molesto no os
dais cuenta y bueno pues ahí tienes a
alguien castigando a los tíos que se
están comportando mal y avergonzando
lees en público así que además me parece
gracioso
no vas a un segundo y a la derecha un
tío salta y se refiere a esta chica con
una palabra absolutamente inapropiada
para llamar a una mujer en inglés
empieza porque tiene cuatro letras no la
piensa repetir es inaceptable
entonces fijaos en un segundo lo que ahí
va a ser un intercambio de opiniones
empieza a ser un intercambio de insultos
y no sólo eso el tío dice perdón o
segundo pero es que ahí y lo podéis ver
hay una mujer haciendo women sporting
está poniendo su bolso en un asiento
desocupado que me impide a mí y
echar lejía en el bolso de las señoras
que dejan su asiento
en un asiento desocupado es porque soy
hombre
y entonces en el centro y oscuro que
están colocados así izquierda la derecha
acción trato como muy muy oportuno llega
una chica y saber el más perdí no está
mal y es verdad nos molesta pero yo creo
que esta tipa no está solucionando
ningún problema al contrario está
haciendo lo peor los tipos no es que se
estén dando cuenta que están algo mal se
están cabreando con nosotras y las están
poniendo en contra es todavía peor bueno
pues a pesar de que lo que decía era muy
sensato y tenía mucho en común con el
chico por milagros de la interlocución
humana se ponen a discutir el yo de la
clase como un gallinero entonces sigo
quietos un segundo
os dais cuenta de que
tesis más o menos lo mismo porque estáis
discutiendo se miraron sonrieron y no
supieron qué responderme no les dije
vale a la chica del fondo le dije dime
una cosa después llegar lo que ha pasado
sigues pensando lo que pensabas dijo que
no dice no le hables que me ha dado
cuenta dice a ver al principio yo veo un
vídeo me hace gracia es un vídeo muñecos
a los que les están pasando cosas y tíos
a los que les están humillando no me
planteo que son personas no me doy
cuenta de que es verdad les está
rompiendo
propiedad privada se está rompiendo los
pantalones nadie quiere que le tienen
legislación lo pide
y entonces les pregunté algo que vuelva
a preguntar a vosotros qué creéis que
habría pasado si en lugar de en una aula
donde estábamos todos hablándonos como
estamos aquí esto hubiera pasado en la
soledad de su habitación la chica del
vídeo -la ikea comenta comparte lon y de
pronto empezaría a recibir pues
probablemente un montón de acoso puede
que insultos a lo mejor incluso alguna
amenaza
creéis que la chica cambiaría su opinión
efectivamente es casi imposible que lo
hiciera de hecho se llama tiene un
hombre es el back fire effect efecto de
retroceso y es lo que pasa cuando
atacamos frontalmente las ideas de
alguien lo que sucede es que respondemos
como ante el ataque de un depredador
tiene motivos biológicos pensando en
nuestras ideas son las que forman
nuestra identidad nuestra personalidad y
lo que es más importante porque somos
animales sociales nos hacen formar parte
de nuestros grupos por eso es tan
difícil renunciar a ellas por eso es
difícil que un terraplén ista deje de
serlo porque se queda en tierra de nadie
y qué habría pasado con el chico
habría cogido habría usado esta palabra
probablemente réprobos habrían dicho
defiéndete pero un montón de gente se
habría enfurecido con razón se habían
enfadado mucho y que habría pasado
habría ganado muchísima difusión porque
porque como dicen en inglés engagement y
senreich meant
los algoritmos llevan favoreciendo
cualquier contenido polémico por encima
de los demás en nuestros timeline desde
hace años y bueno hay que ser ingeniero
mirando en la tele funciona cuántos años
hermano
os imaginais gran hermano que se sientan
a la mesa a resolver sus problemas
socialmente anna me has quitado el yogur
es hijo anthony hambre
pasan a continuar cualquiera que nadie
yo no lo vería es así como funciona
entonces puede perder el hilo espero
recuperar así aquí viene el giro
resulta que un medio local descubre qué
que todavía ha sido un montaje del
kremlin supuestamente para desacreditar
el movimiento feminista en rusia no sé
cuántos de vosotros conocíais este caso
the bird the gardian y otros medios
internacionales se hacen eco de la
noticia resulta que uno de los chicos
sale diciendo que efectivamente es un
actor le habían dado
un recambio de pantalones el presupuesto
espionaje está bajo estos días y la
chica decían que era una influencia era
la que habían pagado para montar todo
esto ella lo desmintió pero a pesar de
todo eso algunos medios quitaron el
vídeo algunos pero el daño ya estaba
hecho
cuántas de las personas que apoyaban lo
que hizo la chica
de ciudad eso estaba mal claro igual mi
activismo no mola si lo estaban
utilizando en contra del movimiento
creciendo
cuántas de las personas probablemente
hombres que fueron engañados por esto
diría reconocerían que igual están a la
que salta que es verdad que las
feministas no están locas pues yo creo
que pocos y menos aún los que cogerían y
compartirían en red en sus redes
sociales el sabes que me equivocado pido
perdón es lo bueno de las redes sociales
no tienes que pedir perdón pensa vistes
lo peor a día de hoy
yo no sé cuál es la verdad no tengo ni
idea
y es por el tamaño de las plataformas es
muy difícil saber qué es verdad y qué es
mentira cuando hay cientos de miles o
incluso millones de personas dando dos
versiones totalmente opuestas de las
cosas y pensando youtube tiene más de
1.900 millones de usuarios mensuales no
registrados somos 7 mil millones de
personas y medio en el mundo pero es que
facebook tiene más de 2 mil 500 millones
de usuarios mensuales eso es más que la
población de india o china los ciudades
con más personas
instagram tiene el doble de usuarios
mensuales que los habitantes que hay en
eeuu
se nos va de las manos es imposible
gestionar todo toda esa comunicación son
no son macro naciones digitales son
continentes digitales con tribus
separadas por kilómetros de distancia
pero unidas por intereses y
desgraciadamente por odios en común es
lo que permite que una persona está
sentada de su pareja sonriéndole en una
escena mientras está siendo
extremadamente cruel con otra persona
millones aquí a miles de kilómetros sin
sentirse mal porque no ve las
consecuencias no ve a esa persona sufrir
hay un límite al número de personas con
las que podemos relacionarnos y no sé si
lo conocéis pero el número 150
se llama el número de ámbar y el nombre
se lo da un antropólogo que fue que lo
descubrió robin dunbar él se dio cuenta
de que este número se repetía a lo largo
de la historia por ejemplo 21 de las
estructuras sociales de
cazadores-recolectores
de las que tenemos datos científicos
fidedignos el número medio de los
habitantes de sus pueblos cuando se
mantenían en paz y armonía era de 148 5
a lo largo de la historia los generales
han intentado mantener sus ejércitos en
un límite de 200 personas a partir de
entonces es difícil de controlar y el
mal comportamiento se disparaba wilber
gore que es el fundador de la empresa
que inventó goretex parece que dio con
este número por casualidad porque en
ningún momento se refirió al anbar al
menos que yo sepa pero sus oficinas
nunca tenían más de 150 personas y
sabéis cómo lo controlaba lo que hacía
era cuando había que poner una plaza de
parking 151 nuevo parking nueva oficina
[Música]
entonces es esa la razón por la que es
tan necesario que volvamos a nuestro
origen al entorno en el que realmente
nos portamos como humanos yo sé que las
redes sociales no nos han engañado nos
han hecho pensar que podríamos saltar
nuestros límites biológicos pero lo
siento trans humanistas hasta que el on
mars no conecte nuestros cerebros con un
ordenador tenemos unos límites hay un
punto del que no puede que no podemos
superar así que por eso insisto que
imagínate tu cuñado gotta box no es
santi abascal es tu cuñado llama le
habla con el que da y vive que te ha
pasado que está pasando
como nos hemos separado tanto su prima
bota pedro sánchez no le puedes ver la
cara debería ser modelo de cortefiel no
kiko no debería estar atendiendo en
cortefiel no pasa nada
con ella es tu prima habla tenemos que
aceptar que hay opiniones diferentes de
las nuestras son totalmente respetables
a lo mejor algunas no bueno pues
entonces hablemos porque el mundo no se
va a construir dejando gente fuera de la
mesa no podemos eliminar las personas
que no nos gusten ni siquiera los que
comen pizza con piña no se puede
así que os pido que
reflexiones sobre ello y que volvamos y
ojo me encantan las redes sociales me
encanta internet creo que son un
complemento perfecto para nuestras
relaciones personales pero es un
complemento no un sustituto así que
aunque parezca que seamos rodeados como
de racistas neonazis y machi nulos
feminazis comunistas golpistas batasunos
y cuando te fijas bien
cuando dejas de twittear con avatares y
te sientas hablar con personas te das
cuenta de que la mayoría no son más que
hay gente que está intentando encontrar
sentido a este mundo en el que estamos
conectados digitalmente con avatares a
cientos de miles de kilómetros pero
estamos rodeados de personas que nos
ignoran porque están en sus móviles
intentando encontrar a alguien que les
presta atención
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]